none of these 35 the father of
classification Linnaeus a great swedish
botanist went around the world literally
and found plants found in section
classified and the inventor basic
classification structure for natural
history and Linnaeus said wait a minute
as he roamed the world he noticed that
even people look differently from one
place to the other and he thought
perhaps even the human species could be
subcategorized into' population he came
up with four americanus asiaticus
Africanist europeans
nevertheless what I what I want to do
and I that you get slide receivers in
seconds without at all he defined these
different human species one of them was
reddish caloric hair black straight
thick wide nostrils scanty beard
obstinate Mary free paints himself with
buying red lines and is regulated by
customer the Indian population and
here's another one of these species sawa
melancholy stiff hair black dark eyes
severe hockey avaricious covered with
loose Scarlets and ruled by opinion the
Asians black phlegmatic relaxed hair
black prism scan silky nose flag lip
stupid women without shame they lacked a
policeman rocky hinterlands negligent
anoints himself with briefs governed by
Caprice the afternoon got one race to go
I'm not going to say to you
white sandwich must do it hair long
flowy eyes blue gentle acute and it
covers himself with clothes vestments
and is governed by law this is the most
distinguished natural historian probably
immune is good and don't have to worry
about all of the words but just imagine
he wanted to not only describe these
species physically and so forth but he
also wanted to give us a sense of what
their character was and I just reread
the key key ones the American Indian
regulated by custom the agent ruled by
opinion the African governed by increase
and the European governed by law so
there it is right in the beginning we
imagine that these different human
species have not just physiological
differences that character logical moral
a difference then about a couple of
decades later a student of linnaeus
German named blumenbach medical doctor
growth extremely important book called
me natural varieties of mankind and he
not only described them differently
using climate theory but sort of did
what Linnaeus did and then he also said
it's really is rank order it really does
and he has Caucasians at the top and
Negro he's OK at the bottom the only
thing that that blumenbach does with
which lilius did not do is he actually
add
a
there there there first slide said it to
me what you've gotten yourself even see
it this is Reuben balls for Casey
mongoloid MLA native american eagle the
only thing he did was he said no there
anything on just four or five and he
separated the asian into two groups of
civic Islanders and the other Asian
population and he gave us the fact that
we now have a color Pentagon we have
white yellow brown red and black this
was in 1776 please so it really very
interesting happen two hundred twenty
years later in the United States
government we caught up we finally
finally decided yes there were five
primary races and this is the OMB
classification 725 time their graces the
Indian Alaska Native agent black African
American Native Hawaiian Pacific
Islander so forth same 55 primary races
in the official statistical system of
the United States we'd simply reproduce
Blue Bottle 220 years later talk about
stickiness in bureaucratic processes and
that's a lot of staying power each
category that it has no consequence not
only did we sort of decided that there
are these five you can't quite tell this
they don't you it is there are five and
I said and then this joint
has two ethnicities yes no is patting
down strap and then of course having
adopted these standards the only using
census they're using everything when
Columbia University reports back in
front of Education about the composition
of student body these are the categories
that they have to use when you take in a
patient in a hospital tick some boxes
these are the categories these five
primary categories you can you sub
categories but you have to be able to
aggregate back these five primary
Kepler's now so that's what we have we
get ready for census 2000 we asked
questions when asked two questions one
is are you Hispanic Latino or Spanish no
or yes and if yes well you can tell us
whether you're watching American Chicano
Puerto Rican Cuban and if you're
expanding than not one of those that you
would write it in in a box so we start
by simply saying the population is is
either expanding non-hispanic and then
we have some sub categories but the
instruction on this question says this
is not a race this is something
different this is a registrant Gorge
exactly about a spanish-language for
example Brazilians are about Hispanic
they don't feed Spanish so there's a a a
national origin linguistic dimension
particular but not raishin okay then we
also asked a race question and you can't
quite see the blumenbach ian categories
in this question but but there there is
this person what is this person's race
white laughs african-american or negro
american indian or alaska native and
then you print in Rhode tribe and then
there's a whole list of other things you
can say yes or no and this the list on
that side Asian Japanese Korean
Vietnamese and so forth are in effect
what work cumin bak meant by the Asian
category and the ones on this side gave
you Hawaiian surf or the Pacific
batteries and in each instance if we
don't give you enough examples then you
can write other kinds of things under
underneath if you want to quickly on
this if you think about this for a
moment it complains many different
things some of the races are there
because they have a cover white black
the American Indian is there because
they belong in enrolled tribe that's a
civil status and if you read the
question what is this person's race this
question is telling you that all these
other things are individual races right
I mean it doesn't actually say like it
said the expanding question are you
expanding origin and then here's some
subcategories here there's no sort of
sense that these are necessarily
subcategories so presumably of Chinese
is its own race creates its own race
Filipino Samoan and so far all races in
this question this particular question
is very proud of the word race the word
itself it appears in the title what is
this person's race it then says up down
here
if you want if you're not one of these
things print your race down here pick
your race then there's another lines of
some other race and then you write that
down then there's something else going
on this question it says mark one or
more boxes that was the result of an
enormously important political argument
in society one of the primary
participants in that in that discussion
is with us today pecho we will share his
own views on it whether we should or
should not have a multiple race option
we chose not to have a hopeful race
options to stand alone category we chose
us to say mark one or more bait race
which gives you multiple races indeed it
if you mark Chinese and Korean you would
not be multiple race even though it the
question reads as if that would be true
but that's not true you can only be
multiple race if you are some
combination of the five primary races by
primary races plus some other race gives
you total of sixty-three possible
combinations some other race if if this
is exhausted if everybody belongs in one
of the five primary races that blue box
told us to pay attention to then what
would some other race why originally in
white and the Australian would be what
that there be the notion of a that's a
good catch onto something bad and
started in it but the American Indian
means to include all kinds of native
peoples of pre pre-colonial eyes dating
ever in tional people's so they could be
from in from Canada from Australia or
whatever we actually don't have a lot of
Aboriginal here probably but that's
that's the category they would go into
it we did they were going to be american
indian/alaska native that doesn't mean
they could write that down and if they
go down we would run it but i'm going to
talk just briefly about to some other
race then i want to be quickly to a
panel up here some other race was
actually put on the census form in 1920
in order to accommodate people that can
be more than one race up until nineteen
twenty started in 1815 1920 we asked the
question mulatto 16 is foreign the
question a lot that went off and then
after 90 on in 1920 and then certain
1930 put in some other race so that
people won't put down two things they
could do it you won't believe I'm about
to tell you this question mark mark one
or more races the faculty five primary
and so forth with through enormous
intense process bureaucratic processes
of public hearings in Congress meetings
around the country tons of academic
meetings and papers and so forth no big
big big process and some other race
wasn't part of that discussion because
that was something left over the
industry the census girl and the OMB
forgot to take it off forgot to take it
off didn't notice it was there and it
had been there to take care of the take
more than one box phenomena but that was
no longer relevant and so it stayed on
the form after the two thousand senses
but Census Bureau sort of said in its
bureaucratic a naive marvelous way
they're just added stations and people
like that you know we better take the
sum of the race off before we get to
2010 because it doesn't give us good
data however
angelo hotel by then the fastest-growing
race in america was mexican air
ninety-seven percent of the people who
wrote something down there or a
mexican-american Central America
Hispanics who said wait a minute you're
not just this thing called some
ethnicity we're also we think we may
even be erased or whatever we don't see
find ourselves in these other lists so
we're going to write ourselves down
there and more about half forty-seven
percent of Hispanics actually end up
writing something down there and I say
the number of people to use that is
almost exclusively is that so that's the
fastest growing race in America some of
the race now I think this is a mess I
think this complaints it's got deep
historical an Ursa behind it it confuses
it call stains races which we don't
think a raisin sunny like the word race
it uses color for some purposes legal
status for other purposes origin
nationality I mean I these are countries
they're not great since 4am sakes of
China Korea Japan Vietnam then there's
this language thing that's mixed up in
there and that takes care of Hispanics
and so forth or something I think it's a
mess and I'll quickly say what a min go
but it's a mask only because it doesn't
sort of map on the population that that
currently lives in this country it's a
mess because we're not even sure what
purpose it has and it's carrying along
in its track three really separate
important purposes and they don't sort
of match one purpose is of course
discrimination racial disparities and
the capacity
computer track disparities and the
effects of slavery effects of genocide
its people American Indian population
and so forth secondly this question is
used heavily to try to sort out which
new population groups are assimilating
successfully into American mainstream
society to the simulation acculturation
of the immigrant population the serger
immigration after 1960s and so forth and
third that isn't clear but again the
catalyst world will confirm this this is
also a question about self identity
about you being what you want to be and
if you want to be two or three things
write them all down and heed the
congressional hearings that put some
other mark one of their box in a sense
this question was a congressional
hearing that stressed the right of
groups to have affirmation
representation so this has got a social
psychological dimension it's got a map
the population of the culture ation
assimilation new America dimension and
it's got the lingering effects of
discrimination the racial disparities
and so forth and I think my argument
quickly is that this particular question
compare even combined with a standing
question can't carry the policy weight
that we're signing to it and the
American people is giving our getting a
little frustrated you're just chatting a
bit ago the number of people who are now
on the right who are saying that answer
the question don't answer the race
question answer the census into
thousands is coming up in a couple of
weeks but don't answer the question this
question has also led you're colorblind
movement in American society take it out
completely don't even ask about race it
gives us all these race-based policies
don't like this and so forth the Chief
Justice in the Supreme Court is on
record saying he doesn't like the fact
that the American system people being
put in all these little boxes and that
we ought to get past that a lot of
complicated politics behind this thing
my own quick argument is that we should
change that question completely to
something that I'm not going to presume
first time ever it in public it's true
see what my colleagues think about it I
do think this society continues to have
a serious problems racial disparities
and that they are rooted in a nasty
political history especially targeted to
do population to the african-american
slaves of course in American Indian and
that we should simply ask a question are
you are you not african-american are you
are you not native american indian and
that we ought to continue to track
source racial justice discriminatory
politics of policies using the answers
to these two questions and anybody who
is neither of those things we could also
be after american and something else and
something else but anyone who is not
those kinds of things it's just in some
other big blob that would include us the
asians and then i would get much much
more refined data on national origin and
length of time in the country how long
have you been here where were your
parents born at they ever lived here
maybe even get a grandparent
dimension to this go back two or three
generations I would use this question to
track the pace at which people are
assimilating a culture ating getting
educated getting healthcare
intermarrying you know whatever and and
so it is since it's as marshal origin
quite it's not a race question it's a
national origin question and you see I I
wouldn't even use the word race in this
question nor what have I used in the
prior question and then finally because
there are complicated pockets where we
still have to worry about disparities
that aren't just sort of driven maybe by
national origin there aren't really do
too much something of a racial sort or
metrics or I would ask a big open ended
question just tell us who you are and
your origin ethnicity you're trying to
raise your ancestry you know I don't
know just mix all those terms up and
just tell us what you are can be
mixtures and that would then allow the
country to identify small population
groups outside of the African American
descent say for example the way the
question now word is worded the recent
immigrant the Somalia or Ethiopian
Islamic milotic who comes from this
country's only been in this country for
10 or 15 years as kids in the school has
no place to go except the African
American category if they don't go there
but since you're it's going to put them
there and all like you know that I can
explain how we do that in a second
fundamentally there's no place for that
person to go here that person would find
themselves they'd be put down on me yogi
they wanted to or what happening so this
question will allow everybody in the
country to present themselves the way
they see themselves along some dimension
of ethnicity tried origin ancestry the
word language in there but I could have
put language in there and support these
sacrament pretenses these aren't
official questions they're trying to get
to the notational idea of what I think
what would accomplish I think what would
be accomplished and I mentioned the
bottom here that we already get
information on language citizenship from
other questions what I think this would
accomplish but one we would continue to
be able to address the consequences
cuddle what happened to the
african-american the Africans who were
enslaved and then subjected gemco
legislation and not not for not until
nineteen sixty beginning to imagine
himself as free citizens of this country
the civil rights we continue to attract
the legacy of that history and continue
to track the legacy of the mistreatment
of the American Indian population and
then we would pick up whether there are
certain origin groups new immigrants are
coming here from certain countries are
not doing very well if I forgot what
those reasons are and then we would have
a sweeping kind of everybody a kind of
question for affirmation for
representation and so forth but also to
see if you could learn some other kinds
of things that would allow you to
examine disparities and have policy
responses to that so we're now going to
shift from me to them
I'll leave the question you can green
image is baggage oh sure all right I
went to the nearest microphone okay well
we now have on the table a little bit of
policy history in a policy proposal
about about racial categories in the
united states census which is I think
critically a place where where this
where we're policy knowledge that is
knowledge that we derived from complex
statistical systems that are that are
that that are deployed and analyzed in
the United States government by
statisticians and by by sophisticated
politically neutral policy analysts as
we're that system meets politics where
that system meets and comes into contact
with with complicated questions about
how things happen in American government
so to respond to the 22 Ken's a little
mini lecture we have three very
distinguished colleagues from my right
to my left Angelo Falcone Angelo is a
political scientist and the president of
the National Institute for Latino policy
he's a very distinguished and prominent
analyst of policy and politics
surrounding the Latino community in the
United States a leading organizer of an
advocate for the Latino community in the
United States to my immediate left we
have Nate personally who is a professor
of law and political science here at
Columbia a leading expert on the law and
politics of elections in the United
State
it's including the issue issues
surrounding the drawing of legislative
districts redistricting all of which all
of which relies very centrally and
critically on census data and uses the
kind of data that ken was describing
intensively to think about issues of to
deal with issues of representation
representation of communities however
defined defined by law defined by
politics defined by policy in in
politics and tonight's left is Ted Shaw
also a professor at Columbia Law School
who came to Columbia a few years ago
after a very long a distinguished career
at the NWA CP Legal Defense Fund
probably the preeminent civil rights
legal organization in the United States
and he was the president of the Legal
Defense Fund for several years before
before coming to columbia so I'm going
to ask each of our panelists Angelo Nate
and Ted to respond in whatever way they
want to Ken's presentation in five
minutes or so and then we'll open it up
to a discussion both among the people at
the table and and you all so let's start
with Angela what I met dr. Pruitt first
time is he had just gotten confirmed to
be director of the census the year 2000
census and they had this reception for
him and he shocked the hell out of me
because he got up and he said you know
he said all the nice things but he said
yeah I've been consulting with the guys
in South Africa they're setting up the
new government and they put in together
the census over there and I told them
don't put the rice question because it's
going to create more problems for your
country if you put the question in that
I said holy this guy's going to be
messing around with the race and
Hispanic question these people in
Washington they're driving me crazy
because we just spent all this time
lobbying for these stupid things that
make sure that you know they're included
but one of the problems with I think
Ken's presentation is that it's it's
it's like rational
it's this thing doesn't work I mean
think about how we got to the point
where we have this mishmash of you know
kinds of question that's based on
congressional testimony scientific
surveys people tested these questions up
and down on what stuff and this is
decades and you wind up with this stuff
which is like confusing as hell and
which is of you know of limited value in
some areas you know this mostly no
multiple choice race thing to me was a
total waste of time i'm willing to three
percent of the people check that stuff
off I don't know how you do with those
numbers you know it's just a bunch of
categories that you're basically just
the brush aside and say look we're going
to focus on single race the people in
terms of voting rights act and all of
these kinds of things so the politics of
this is so intertwined that's really
difficult to have a rational discussion
and then as is i think can mention the
question of the role of race in American
society something that is is a hotly
debated issue rather the continuing
relevance of the race questions and the
Hispanic questions now i can tell you
politically what happens i'm also chair
of the census Advisory Committee on the
Hispanic population and we have a black
but you know the categories each have a
committee and what happens when these
numbers are you know when we these
thought these things are tested is the
bottom line is not all these things
rational but which combination of
questions or order of questions yields
the most number for your group so right
now for example there are some people
that are trying to raise consciousness
with afro Latinos and they're telling
people who are dark-skinned Latinos to
make sure check off black on the race
question well I know the reaction is
going to be in the black community wait
a minute you take it away our blacks our
black numbers to include them in the
Hispanic category and that's part of the
politics here in terms of these
questions out there they're right now in
the 2010 census they're going to be
testing these questions different
combinations of these things not quite
what I can lay it out there but similar
in terms of looking at things like
combining the Hispanic with the race
questions it's a 111
question that's one thing- also testing
the other the race question but in terms
of african-americans blacks and you know
they're going to be testing what happens
if you take out the Negro they said you
know that you saw the controversy around
inclusion of the term Negro in that
question so right now there's the
testing that's going to be occurring and
so this debates they're going to start
up again at the beginning past their you
know the 2010 census in terms of the
research that the Census Bureau is going
to be doing in terms of looking at how
these different combinations of the
questions different wording of the
questions including naughty not using
for example the word race in the
question and see what that does but the
politics of this is a tough part that
you know people are going to be looking
at bottom lines in terms of numbers for
their community people have a vested
interest different groups in making sure
that they're well represented in the
census and there's a tremendous amount
of suspicion when we receive the first
report last year from the group that at
the census fear the staff that they're
going to be testing the question just
testing the question during the 2010
census most of the members of the
committee of mexican-american I'm the
only Puerto Rican and then there's a
Salvadorian woman up and we're sitting
there and I just got on relatively new
on the committee scared the hell out of
me the members of the committee almost
through the sense of staff people out
the door they were like a rage that
they're testing these questions after
all the time we spent during the the
last ten years lobbying for these
questions now they're going to test them
again and maybe change them holy I
mean they just jumped all over them like
I said whoa my god and it really shook
them up so this is kind of kind of a
visceral kind of reaction to the stuff
as well it has to do with suspicion why
they doing this has to do with the
politics of it will Latinos be counted
less because of these shifts and that
kind of I think overtakes a discussion
rather than the rationality by the way I
was very happy to see the beavis and
butt-head reaction you guys had to the
you penis thing courage
thanks very much info how does want all
of that right thank you for having me
here let me start by also making a pitch
for my course over in the other building
for you all since I don't get sepa
students which is I teach a class on law
and politics particularly a regulation
of elections and things like that we've
talked about redistricting voting rights
political parties campaign finance all
of that kind of stuff and I would be
great to have some of you take it in the
fall it you know it dovetails with a lot
of your interests in this I come here
today wearing multiple hats as is often
the case when I talked about the census
in racial categories which is that I'm a
law professor and political scientist
and i'ma someone who uses the data
particularly as as someone who draws
legislative districts so I've been
appointed on several occasions by courts
to draw redistricting maps for Congress
and state legislatures some some that
are even in effect and I'll tell you
some stories from that let me let me
start with just to give you a sense of
what how the data senses that are used
by those of us in the business as Ken
mentioned there there were 63 potential
racial combinations from the last census
because of the multiple race check off
that actually understates it because
they're 126 once you add in whether
someone is Hispanic or not and so you
describe every level of census geography
from the smallest block up to the state
level along those racial categories but
as can mention the OMB developed
guidelines for reaggravated back into
six races or five races and and my
takeaway or what I should say one thing
I want to suggest here is that the
actual question is a little bit less
important than how we aggregate the race
afterwards what we do with the data in
terms of describing the population so
for example if you're going to have a
cow
child category at the end why not just
why don't we scrap the whole enterprise
and and if we think that we we have a
good job we can do a good job at
aggregating the data into certain
categories want to just say describe
your race right to everyone forget about
what the specific questions for African
American or Indian etc you just say you
know what is described your race /
ethnicity right and if we believe that
the census can sort of take those hand
written descriptions and then so the
computers for the most part can
reallocate back into certain racial
groups or do it in several different
ways well then that that could sort sort
of solve the problem but one thing that
that I would also urge is that in
developing policy in this area we should
avoid the attractiveness of conceptual
neatness and sort of self-expression
that in designing the race question and
pushing policy in this area that that
primarily we should decide what goals we
want the data to serve right and then
develop the question in order to achieve
that and so it is true that the data are
used for many purposes and the politics
around it to have this feeling of
competition for self-expression as well
as for illness or to see which groups
are are larger than the others but
principally I viewed the census race
question as useful first as ken said to
evaluate discrimination claims and I'll
talk about that in a second how that
happens and then also it's critical I
mean we don't just use census data for
redistricting federal funding etc it
describes the American population and
anybody who does research not only into
race but even something as simple as
polling design right any other poll that
we run election polls uses the census as
its baseline in order to stratify the US
population and to sort of set benchmarks
in order to get accurate impressions
about people's opinions across a range
of areas so let me just say two things
about this so
first as ken said there it is relevant
the senses that are used for civil
rights enforcement about how does that
happen the across different areas of the
law we often need to measure the impact
right of a particular law policy
decision on racial groups and so it's
not sometimes it's very easy to measure
in to find sort of smoking on gun
evidence of racist intent or something
like that but that's that's often quite
rare you have to figure out the impact
that a decision or policy is having on
on specific groups in the context of
redistricting and the Voting Rights Act
that means often that you ask the
question whether the districts are drawn
in such a way as to deny to a racial
group it's equal opportunity to elect
candidates of its choice that's the
section 2 of the Voting Rights Act and
those that is often led then to judges
and the courts or during the redrawing
of districts in order to ensure that for
example we have majority minority
districts in areas where we think that
that the Voting Rights Act requires it
in order to evaluate the impact right of
a redistricting plan you have to know
something about the population that's
same is true with an employment decision
right if an employer has a workforce
that is only ten percent
african-american but you know from the
census that fifty percent of the
surrounding community is
african-american right that will be
useful in trying to assess the impact of
a particular policy right and to allege
that there might be some discrimination
that's going on there so the truth is
this the this reordering of the question
is not terrible it doesn't really make
much of a difference in terms that the
way you've done in terms of civil rights
enforcement so long as we can now
identify the communities who are
african-american American Indian
Hispanic of course it's a
political non-starter for reasons that
that can sort of express an Angela did
because you know it has particularly
with the Hispanic independent Hispanic
question on the census that has become a
real symbol of well it has demonstrated
the rise in the Hispanic community in
the United States and has become a sort
of a critical I think symbolic win in
some ways for that community on the
census form itself nevertheless at the
same time I think there's no real reason
to separate out African Americans
American Indians and not have it has
been if you're going to have those
separate categories in earlier question
and it remains the case that Hispanics
are in terms of comprising the universe
of civil rights claims that you get or
not only the increasing the size of the
population but they are when you're
talking about whether it's title seven
kind of litigation or redistricting
litigation for sure increasingly they're
going to be the plaintiffs and so to
take them out and treat them differently
doesn't seem to me to further anything
although I understand there might be
kind of conceptual reasons why one might
think that's the right thing to do I
think that probably if you're going if
one is concerned about tracking the
legacies of discrimination that you'd
probably keep it in there now in in
terms of usefulness for research I mean
there's a lot in here that you that you
propose that I think is helpful i mean
the ancestry kinds of questions serve a
whole different purpose that the census
isn't really isn't the short form of the
census is not helping with right now but
we can think of all kinds of questions
that we might want to put on the short
form of the said says there isn't a
citizenship question right on the census
so we don't know who an american citizen
is and who isn't there are good reasons
why we don't want to do that because if
you if you make this you know if there's
any potential deterrent effect right for
people filling out the census
as of the fear that I NS would get ahold
of it then that would chill
participation but you know we've used
when Ken was running the census they had
the long form of the census which was
sent out to one out of every six
Americans now they do a small sample of
three million people every year actually
of every type of question about where
they live they ask them about
citizenship they asked about ancestry
etc and so I these questions on on
ancestry I think are very interesting
and also sort of raised the question as
to what other kinds of information do we
want from the population at large
because to be honest the fact that I
think you can correct mckennin from
wrong is it what three-fifths of the
actual short form right now is dedicated
to race something like that so that is
the only so the majority of the
information of the space on a census
form that them that the US population is
getting it just deals with race and
there are there other things that we
would like to to know as well I'll end I
guess just by by suggesting you know
that and and this is something I don't
know enough about we should think about
all the other areas of research where we
use racial categories so the even
medical research right uses the census
racial categories to track progression
of diseases in certain communities etc
and that when you know more about how
different constituent groups who use the
data would like to see the racial
question posed that that is also a way
to get information on how to formulate
the the next census race question thanks
name Ted I I want to start by agreeing
with Ken with respect to the big picture
which is that the Census and the way the
census talks about the the issue of
identity who we are is a mess that's
clear I also want to add
that it's no more a mess in my view than
this country's jurisprudence on race
particularly as having been defined by
the Supreme Court and there's a strong
connection between these two sets of
messes if you if you allow me so I think
it's very important to be much more
deliberate and careful about terminology
and how we use terminology when we talk
about what we call race in this country
because we do in many respects confuse
and conflate race color national origin
ethnicity and we talk about them as if
they're all interchangeable and they are
not my view for example on the use of
the term white which kind of stands out
and some of the one of the slides in
particular which refers to all the other
groups in terms of either ethnicity or
national origin and then there's white
you know I think we need to think about
and a lot of people have begun to think
about what whiteness means what purpose
does that category serve I understand
European American I also understand
whiteness today and I think being white
historically in this country and much
more than we want to acknowledge now
still serves one purpose and that is
white supremacy it is oppositional if
you think about being white and I see
some of you exchanging looks but I want
you to think about this if you think
about being white what does it mean
except distinguishing a category of
people who are of European ancestry from
everybody else you know it's kind of
like a case that I remember working on
involving scholarships for
african-american
students that were declared
unconstitutional at the University of
Maryland and during the time that we
were litigating this case of the Legal
Defense Fund we looked and we found all
kinds of scholarships in this country
that were in effect national origin or
ethnically based or gender basis said oh
we found scholarships for descendants of
French Huguenots we found scholarships
for Italian students from upstate New
York we found scholarships for students
who are from China in the United States
or Chinese ancestry we found
scholarships for young women of the high
moral character who did not use tobacco
and all these scholarships now stay with
me for a minute on this my view was that
I had no problem with scholarships for
students of Italian descent from upstate
New York I don't think doesn't stop
scholarships were created for the
purpose of discriminating against
everyone else in a sense of saying that
they were inferior Italian Americans got
together proud of their their national
origin etc fun of these scholarships I
don't see that in the same way I would
see a scholarship for white students and
some people say well the symmetry is you
have a scholarship for African American
students or black students so why do you
allow that you don't allow scholarship
for black students or white students
rather well the answer is you have to
look at our history and what whiteness
means and what it means to be black
african-american and the fact that for
the most part except for recent
immigrants from Africa for black people
in this country you know it's hard to
find out it has been hard now we we have
more science we can do it a little bit
better but race has been ethnicity so we
can flayed all of these things I could
spend a lot more time talking about it
my my main point here is that I agree
that it's a mess having said all that I
think that
I want to focus on a few points 1 and
professor personally nate has already
laid out the legitimate uses in my view
of tracking what we call race or
ethnicity or identity whatever we call
it but I think we need to be more
specific about what we're talking about
but there are legitimate reasons and to
know who we are as a country it's still
important it's still important in so
many different ways people like you
mentioned before the panel glenn beck
they rail on the right against these
census categories and they say don't
answer the race question is being
counting and they equate any race
consciousness with racism and that's a
false equation i can talk a lot more
about that we do have to be careful
about how we use what we call race or
ethnicity or national origin but the
equation of race consciousness or you
know ethnicity consciousness with racism
is a false equation on its face a lot
more that we could say about that you
know I've litigated voting rights cases
litigated every kind of civil rights
case there is by now and I understand
how important it is to use evidence that
relies in part on these classifications
as Professor person who talked about now
a couple of other points about systemic
issues one is that your proposal impart
and way it deals with Latinos or
Hispanics and Latinos or Hispanics you
know it's a broad categorization and it
really in some respects mass many
subgroups and the same thing is true for
Asian Americans we're going to be honest
about the same thing is true for
african-americans now with more and more
immigration of Africa
the United States first generation of
second-generation Africans or people of
African descent from the Caribbean so
even though we have this this old and
enduring issue that is rooted in slavery
and Jim Crow segregation that only ended
about 40 years ago if we're going to be
honest about it and that legacy legacy
still reaches into our policies and our
our status today it's much more
complicated than it would be if we would
have simply look at you know
african-americans is one homogeneous
group uh but let me shift for a minute
and close by saying something on a
somewhat personal level that but but
only for the purpose of illustrating
what would talk about here okay so I sit
here in front of you a very light
skinned person who some of you if you
look to me you might say well I'm not
sure what his ethnicity is I'm an
african-american but obviously i am not
solely african-american and i took one
of these tests not long ago skip gates
up at harvard encouraged me to take one
of these tests you know he's making
money off of this stuff and you know one
test came back and traced Native
American ancestry many African Americans
claim it not all habit i do but also you
could look at me and you might say well
maybe his parents are you know in an
integration of biracial marriage uh no
and in fact in my family as light skin
as i am my first cousin to dark skin but
we had no idea who any of the white
people were in my family going back as
long as anybody had a memory or those
who knew as we say in the
african-american community those who
know don't tell and those who tell don't
know so if people knew they weren't tell
them
and I did some work this summer and I'm
continuing on this work and finally did
find a white ancestor going back to the
Revolutionary War who was a an orphan
partner Revolutionary War came back from
the war blind to Virginia and in a
scenario that tempts one to think about
what's the African American comedian who
had this to Dave Chappelle and some of
you know the skid I'm talking about
right if you don't know you can talk to
somebody next to you and that can
explain it afterwards but he married not
married he couldn't marry was illegal
but he lived with a woman of African
descent she was designated mulatto and
undoubtedly you know she was mulatto
because some slave master had taken
liberties with her to put a kind which
is the way I think as I best I
understand it most of the blood in me
that is European by origin came into my
family I don't know of anybody who
married somebody white except for this
individual who couldn't marry the point
I'm making is that in spite of all of
that not knowing and knowing all that
now my identity my experience where I
grew up the way I live my interest has
all been defined as african-american
when in fact I'm probably America in
many ways but if the census were to
allow a change which would take people
who either look like me and many
african-americans because of the
internalization of racism still want to
be anything else blood african-americans
some African many african-american are
now proud to be african-americans but
i'm not in favor of eliminating a
categorization process which allows us
to count african
Americans because of all the reasons
that Professor personally talked about
so the bottom line knows that this ends
up being deeply personal for many
Americans who and what they are and who
they claim of what they claim many of us
don't even know entirely what we are
what we are we're making an election or
an election has been made for us I
suspect in time this will only become
more and more muddled and in time we may
end up with a census form which allows
people to make the kind of Elections
that you talk about but we still in this
country and the final thing I'll say we
still have a particular legacy and this
is where the jurisprudence is screwed up
American jurisprudence denies the
peculiar experience of African Americans
that is it denies the peculiarity of
that experience as a constitutional
matter it doesn't recognize it and you
mentioned the peculiar experience of
Native Americans there are still some
particular issues that need to be worked
out because of that legacy and I'm not
ready to abandon that even though the
idiots who are jumping in color
blindness now having hijacked it and
turned it on its head are using it
against all kinds of attempt to pursue
an agenda that continues to address the
legacy of inequality rooted in racism
slavery and Jim Crow segregation all
right thanks to all three of you what I
want to do now is I want to ask a couple
of questions to the panelists that have
based on things that have come up in the
discussion and I'll ask you can can jump
in on these things too and then we'll go
around on the panel a little bit and
then we'll we'll take questions from
from you all as as they come up but the
first thing I want to do is pick up on
something Nate said and that is you put
out the proposition that what we need to
do when we're thinking about
census in this particular instance but I
think about any sort of data collection
enterprise for policy purposes is think
about the purpose to which we want to
put the data what do we want to use the
data for and that the answer to that
question should guide the way we
construct the data system and construct
the evidence that we're collecting each
of you talked a little bit around this
question but I'd like each of you
including Ken to answer this question
answer the question what's the purpose
for which we should be using these
racial categories as we measure them in
the census let's just go down the table
and asked Angela to that well I mean
it's it's from straightforward as people
mentioned to trying to look at
disparities and where they basically
show discrimination that's an issue but
the problem is that people are right now
politically trying to turn that on its
head in terms of how you can potentially
use these data you know you have a if I
want to get a major policy maker like
really bored and stuff you know you know
when you talk to somebody like the I
start floating like in front and stuff
is when I talk about discrimination and
and these disparity issues that go man
we're going to talk about that that's
all you have to talk about there are
some agencies for example the Federal
Communications Committee a commission
used to ask the broadcast television
stations to submit breakdowns of the the
workforce over ten years ago they
stopped doing doing that because I guess
I don't know it was ugh the Supreme
Court found that it was discriminatory
to have this information so now we can't
enforce we can't gauge what kind of
progress we're making in terms of
diversifying the the broadcast
television stations except you know you
watch on the tube when you see more
Hispanics and stuff like that but the
guys will make the decisions behind the
camera we sometimes have no idea so just
kind of monitoring this kind of stuff is
a really important at a very basic level
or things like voting rights so when we
talk about redistricting it's based on
the notion of that there's a racially
polarized electorate out there and all
you have to do is is look at the results
of the 2008 Oh life
racially and you see that even at the
national level how polarized it was all
you have to do is read do a google thing
and put down a you know racial
discrimination or whatever and you'll
see report after report on all health
housing and you see these kinds of
racial disparities in this country
consistently the process or you know
we're able to document this stuff the
problem is the interpretation of that
documentation it's over the years which
have been happening especially under the
Bush administration is that that stuff
has been turned and to kind of blame the
victim kind of thing no longer looking
at kind of structural inequalities
because the data doesn't it's hard to
make those kind of connections so it's
it's not a question so much of the data
but the interpretation of data these
days also the fact that I'd say under
the Bush administration there was a
tremendous effort to kind of really
weaken the enforce civil rights
enforcement power of the federal of the
federal government in these agencies so
these data were not taken as seriously
as they should have when you see the
kind of consistency of the kind of
patterns that you see there but again
the question is is kind of one of
basically your interpretation of those
disparities is it really the result of
kind of a racism structural problems or
is it an individual problem these people
just you know it can't keep jobs and
stuff like that so it makes it really
difficult I think to kind of talk about
this these days and then there are these
other uses for example in the Latino
community just the idea of affirming the
existence of the community are when we
talk about the census now you know
people talk about the benefits of the
census in terms of you know more monies
coming into your neighborhoods that kind
of thing or you know reapportionment but
also in the Latino community I always
tell people it kind of reintroduces the
Latino community every ten years the
American society and generates a whole
discussion that's something that that is
valued very much in the community just
just that acknowledgement and the fact
that it's growing so we get people in
the community know coming oh my god
we're growing this so many Latinos now
then you get the other part of the u.s.
going holy there's so many Latinos
now and it starts a very interesting
conversation every ten years so some
revisions follow up before we move on
given that
set of purposes that you have to come
out of these data what is your optimal
classification system instead of
questions on the census look like do we
have it is the question that we have now
the right one should we change it
somehow either in the direction that ken
is suggesting or or some other direction
if you could write the question as the
you know census dictator what would you
do well you know right now unfortunately
looking at the positives I've sat down
with can a few times and I've kind of
sit on it makes sense but then I'm
looking and looking at the politics of
it and for the Latino community it was a
battle to get this kind of recognition
and right now man we got our own
question I don't know who's gonna mess
with that so you see anyone leaving a
lot yeah you know Nate all right sighs I
sell both both questions what are the
purposes and what's the what's the right
question so that as I was saying so the
purpose I sort of split the purposes
into two which is one for the law and
the other is for research and so for the
law as i said the voting rights act I
mean all civil rights statutes in some
way are they necessitate the use of some
kind of racial category or Rachel data
and then in particular you look at the
Voting Rights Act title 7 and civil
rights act Fair Housing Act you know I
guess I certainly education policy and
desegregation right you need to know the
racial composition of who lives where in
order to make assessments of how
integrated community may be and now or
segregated and how certain laws will
affect those populations right also
obviously for affirmative action I mean
adding on to civil rights laws you need
to if not that the census you'll need it
with other other surveys as well in
other application forms etc so those are
the legal requirements then what about
for research this I'm a little bit less
shura because
can only speak from one's field you know
so I think you'd get a different and in
Canada actually years ago we're part of
a symposium at Bard College where we had
all kinds of different scholars from
different fields talking about the
multiple race check off option on the
census and how it would have an impact
for their research so you know doctors
would have a different ideas to what how
what racial categorisation would help
them political scientists might have
other ideas and impulse ters as I said
are important in this realm as well to
get a sense of what kind of information
will help them describe the population
in a way so that they can then
apparently the people who make
television shows it's important yes yes
right right so you can market market
research right all of that I mean just
to give you an example of I mean I
follow supreme court brief last year you
that use census data which was this was
one the constitutional challenge of the
Voting Rights Act and you know one of
the questions that was raised in the
case was to what extent section 5 of the
voting rights act as a piece of
legislation that only applies to some
parts of the country and not others and
so in the first page of the brief of
those who are challenging the
Constitution on the Voting Rights Act
they say look we have a black president
the Voting Rights Act means something
very different now than it did 40 years
ago and and obviously the Obama election
was was mentioned is something that that
you know raised concerns among those who
are challenging the constitutionality of
the Voting Rights Act and so one things
we could show right was just doing some
simple bivariate plots of the race of
say the population breakdown of counties
on the x-axis right and the obamas vote
share on the y-axis right now you need
senses that in order to do that and what
you could show for example is that that
Obama did not do as well among whites in
the areas that are covered
by the voting rights act as he did
outside the covered jurisdictions and
not only did that sort of seems obvious
because most of the areas that are
covered in the south so of course he's
you know he's going to do worse among
southern whites but then you could also
compare it take go for years prior and
compare well how how much better or
worse did he do among whites than John
Kerry right turns out he did do better
than among whites then John Kerry did
four years early outside of the areas
that are covered by the Voting Rights
Act but he didn't in the areas that were
covered by the Voting Rights Act and
unless you have census data where you
can match up you know the counties or
the districts or the blocks racial pub
or precincts racial composition with say
the vote percentages that certain
candidates get you can't make those kind
of arguments oh no and what what I said
you know as I said about that the what
question I would like I I'm the the
format of the question is not as
critical for me as to what data then are
prepared by the Census Bureau that they
give you big so so if we can
operationalize Ken's last question which
is sort of an open-ended question right
and say well describe your race right
then the quite then we're going to have
some kind of heuristic right as to how
we're going to then wreak attagirl
already now that that that's what we
have under the sum up as ken was hinting
it is talked on the some other race
category the census will take people out
of the some other race category and
reallocate them to other racial groups
and so this you know if you just have an
open-ended question allows for
self-expression if that's important to
people but then the question is how
would we reallocate people afterwards I
don't have much to add to what natives
OD said about the uses of these data and
to what I said earlier about the uses of
these data I think that the data is
still very important and it's a terrible
mistake to equate the collection of data
with discrimination itself that's a
terrible mistake but some people are
doing that very deliberately with
respect to the questions as i said
earlier at least i hinted i probably
would be okay with the elimination of
the term race and the use of ethnicity
or national origin those kinds of terms
race is very confusing ultimately and as
we know it is a social construct but it
is a very very powerful social construct
in this country so as I said before I
would be in favor of being very very
conscious and deliberate about the
terminology we're using and exactly what
we're trying to to to measure all right
before we go on to another round of this
ken I want to respond to these pot shots
no I won't I mean it's too important to
get competition going than me go down
the line I just a couple of small things
really though your edification so to
speak the certainly the the web Angelou
said about the importance of the size of
one's group is is a big deal and there
is no doubt but that over the last 20 30
years the Hispanics have done a better
job at sort of I don't want to overstate
this but of using the census as a tool a
political tool for affirmation of the
group for even some cohesion of the
group and certainly for parading the
results in all kinds of political forum
the the the only group whatever we call
it race group ethnicity group or
whatever the only group that's mentioned
in any law that tells you you have to
count this screw
is the expanded group the law talks
about all kinds of things talks about
racial minorities it never talks about
african-americans the law itself about
the census is what we count there's all
kinds of euphemisms even in the United
States Constitution long history of you
but but there is a public law that says
if you count anybody of an ethnic or
racial or whatever national origin
category if you count anybody you have
to count Hispanics it was a brilliant
and very early we're not going back in
the 1960s and protecting the other line
is is a part of that because so many
Hispanics find it convenient people go
to that line and therefore not become
one of the primary races even though we
may put them back in those categories
from their point of view they've
asserted their self and they're right so
the first point then is just a really
underlying what Angelo said is there's a
powerful political force between simply
being large and certainly as Ted knows
didn't talk about in this particular
comments today but the the opposition of
the n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund and
other or other ethnic groups and racial
groups to the multiple race question the
addition of this mark one or more was an
argument with dilute our numbers because
Mara african-american white would
somehow be in a different category that
would separate or reduce the number of
african-americans in the census numbers
so there was a dilution of numbers
political argument that just one quick
thing i want to emphasize and importance
of that from the point of view of the
politics of all of us i would and they
say that i wouldn't at all I never
intended to take Hispanics out of the
strategy and I just think we ought to
get to Hispanics as a national origin
question where did you come from where'd
your parents come from how long have you
been here I would actually put it in a
if this panel were made up of
immigration of experts rather than
racial justice experts which is
fundamentally what what what is what is
the case up here today they would be
much more interested in the national
origin how long have you been here where
we are we're parents here and so forth
and so on because there is a kind of a
residue of anxiety about the how we
treat new Americans how we treat me
people who come to this country and do
we treat them as equally now just one
other small thing the back on the mask
problem the Asian category is
particularly particularly vexing because
what you got in the Asian quote-unquote
asian population the umbrella asian
population is you've got incredible
success stories obviously a
korean-american japanese american
chinese americans and then you've got
groups that aren't making it very well
at all vietnamese wrong so forth
Southeast Asians so you got a category
that you're trying to sort of deal with
racial justice and it just doesn't work
simply doesn't work if anything if if
you did colorblind identity blind of
admissions policies in higher education
in California just test scores just
meritocracy I don't know eighty-seven
percent Asian women at Berkeley the only
way to get diversities make sure you
don't have too many Asian women but no
it'sit's if you look at the test scores
you're looking at thousands of 800
scores in the SATs and among Asian
population groups and so you gotta you
gotta get you get this kind of category
called Asian which from racial justice
point of view is carrying a lot of funny
stuff in it that just doesn't work sorry
I'll stop I mean I won't stop I'll
answer your questions Robert then I'll I
think there are three big purposes and I
think it's absolutely true that you
ought to start with a purpose and design
the question what's actually happen
the history of the racial classification
system of the United States is we
started with a classification and then
we would around founding different
purposes for it the three fish law the
race science in the 19th century
discriminatory practices of emigration
policy and then on the positive side the
affirmative action civil rights laws
there 40 Rights Act and so forth but in
each case the category just kind of get
reproduced to reproduce and reproduced
and it kept changing the purposes
attached to it and I think we've run out
of steam on that and so I would start
with three purposes that this country
ought to do with the lingering effects
of a very peculiar a particular type of
maltreatment of groups because they were
of a race group secondly some better
measure our metric of how well new
Americans are doing by ethnicity are by
a national origin or by language group
or whatever it is and so far as we think
that's a deterrent to making your way in
this society and in third some kind of
affirmation let people express
themselves what we will actually do with
those data is a little unclear to me
other than obviously a lot of
interesting research I should just
technically say that if you did have
that broad open hood question just write
down what you want to the technical
capability of collecting those data
encoding them is very good we live in
the American Indian question you write
in your tribe and in even in the 2006 of
technologies improve since then the
intelligent character recognition
optical recognition hour of success rate
was over ninety-nine percent the
fantastic capacity to sort of do that so
you could actually have that kind of
thing and then have all kinds of
interesting so that but but back to
Robert's question and it could really
make you do want to start with what is
the purpose and then you ask yourself
what is the measurement strategy that
allow you to reach that purpose
that's the rational argument linear
policymaking walk in me but the other
half of me says well Angelo is right
you're not going to get there and
therefore you go to try to come up with
something you might be able to get you I
just want to say one thing which is just
so people aren't under misimpression
which is that the census race question
has undergone incredible changes I mean
that's obvious given given you know the
origins where you it was principally
trying to decide how much you know black
blood the respondent had for purposes of
the three-fifths clause as well as that
the sense of the Constitution says you
know that to account Indians not taxed
so you had to find know the number of
Indians as well but you know there are
times when Jews were category on the
census there been times when all kinds
of other groups have have been on the
census I think though and tell me if I'm
wrong on this is this the first time in
two censuses that there hasn't been any
changes to the race question this is
great because the 2010 census will be
the same as the two thousand census form
and so that's it so so what is this I
think you maybe suggest like I've kind
of calcification you know the category
I'll be very quick acting this question
but because you're both right and wrong
obviously you look at a question across
history and all kinds of things came and
went but the fundamental structure that
did not the fundamental structure went
through three white black red 24 white
black red yellow now there was a period
while it was not clear the Chinese are
clearly some alien race but maybe the
Japanese arm because they're Christian
and maybe we're not going to sort of put
them into this category and that went on
for truck you know two or three decades
that argument but by the end of the 19th
century we had decided all of those
kinds of people work asian they were in
a race group then we went through a
period where my gosh oh what about these
what about these wrong kind of whites
he's Italian White's you after all a
cafe
these polish white so after all Jewish
and so there was some playing around
with this new ethnicity a more refined
way but by when the dust settled they
were all white and when the dust settled
everybody's a black everybody is one of
these five primary groups just that's
where the dust settled we started with
three we went to four and then we added
the fifth when we added the Pacific
Islander and then the other incredibly
interesting thing is we tagged along and
ethnicity called the Hispanic and so now
whatever you want to call these groups
but we clearly have six major groupings
in the society well in terms of size you
know I just wanted to say that between
2000 and the current census there was
one little difference and that was a
they didn't include the examples on
Hispanic did some other Hispanic and
that created all sorts of havoc but uh
these little technical things but the
other thing I want to say in terms of
research purposes for example one things
that I find fascinating as Ken mentioned
that some other category in the Hispanic
I mean in the race question is seen when
you talk to census people it's like a
nuisance it's like this painted what do
we do with this stupid thing let's get
rid of it last time that happened I
remember congressman Serrano uh
you know a little amendment into uh wow
I did put in a call but uh butter and
and and there was resistance to changing
it but the other thing that the reason
was that in the Latino community there's
a certain this whole research program
around the fact that we reject American
racial categories and that's an
affirmation that we reject it will put
in things like some other races they'll
put in Puerto Rican is a race those
types of things and it's a source of
kind of pride right that we're distinct
from these other American people I just
fall into these stupid these get
categories that's part of it and also
there's been a whole research program
around Latino Studies cultural studies
around this issue of race is a lot of
research on racial identity of Latinos
and how it's different than all that
stuff so what happens is
when you talk to the census people they
go ahead this thing's a nuisance it's
not useful in the Latino community
that's taken as also kind of attacking a
whole area or research within the Latino
community that is valued by a whole
bunch of people so even when you talk
about common you know agendas on common
uses there are differences in terms of
the different communities and how they
use the information how they perceive
that the the data and the questions okay
Mike you can just come in because you
know I agree with and acknowledge the
dynamic than Angela just identified but
i also want to underscore another
dynamic and i think we all recognize
which is that within the Hispanic
community Latino community you know race
cuts across it you know it may make a
difference to be a black person from a
dark skinned person from Porter with as
opposed to a white person from Puerto
Rico or from the Dominican Republic or
whatever and in fact it's not only
Latino communities Hispanic communities
but if you look across the world either
within or outside of the United States
skin color dark skin is a cause for
great discrimination and so part of the
concern within the african-american
community was the continued ability to
measure and identify that discrimination
to quantify when it goes on all right
Mike my gambit worked yeah I'm sorry we
ought to get real but the district
problem just wanted a quick thing just
underline what what Ted you said it is
really important to know that there is a
good research literature on the fact
that darkness itself skin color matters
enormously that is within so-called race
groups the dark a huge part of that race
grupos the asians whether it's a Native
American Indians whether it's the
African Americans do not do as well as
the lighter skinned of quote-unquote
members of that race group
and there is there is something really
deep again the discriminatory practice
of world history which is is tied to
darkness itself and you know a lot of
metaphors do this so there are people
who say and they're not dumb at all for
the user that throw all of this
categorization out and simply measure
the darkness of the skin and we will
have a better measure of discrimination
than these kind of gross categories
called Asia and african-american and so
what oh that is complicated because some
research we had done we had a we were
able to do as household servant years
back Latino national political survey
and we were able to get the the
interviewers to kind of rate the
person's skin color and we asked the
census questions and I did I remember I
did a paper on this and looking at the
correlation between skin color and the
racial classification is self
identification and found they're
actually very local correlation between
the two and so and then I look at the
work of the Doug Massie and these guys
looking at the effect of sin color and
for the Regan communities in terms of
segregation and I'm saying winner is
this if he's using the census thing and
there's a correlation through the skin
color and how people perceive themselves
there's a disconnect there and it's hard
to explore because within the census you
can't look at you can't look at it so
and there's also the issue about which
we didn't talk about how as you have
multiple racial categories or even
multiple national origin categories the
issue of which one takes priority which
is your primary one in which is
secondary which is also lost in all
these questions you know because you
know that's that and you know i think
the National Health Statistics people
have a question that actually has which
is your primary identity so that's also
kind of missing as well okay we've got
on the table before i get to question if
we've got on the table now six or seven
different reasons to be asking this
question there's numbers you want to
identify the size of communities for
reasons of political power and voting
power or the flow of money and other
kinds of resources to communities we've
got a particular history the lingering
effects of
past past discrimination and past
disparities that need to be identified
address remedy through these data you've
got the question of what Ken called new
Americans a culturally acculturation
assimilation the flow of communities
inside the country you've got the
question of racial and ethnic
identifying and remedying disparities of
a variety of kinds among a lot of
different communities whether they're
sort of historically discriminated
against communities or not you've got
the issue of just simply enforcing the
law there are laws and court judgments
that require the use of these data or
data like these in order to in order to
to implement laws you've got this sort
of affirmation of the community
community there's communities that want
to be able to point to their numbers in
the census data and say yes here we are
we're this size we're bigger than we
used to be we're bigger than those other
guys and there's research their
communities of scholars of social
scientists of policy analysts of people
in policy schools all over the world or
Laurel all over the country at least who
are you know just salivating waiting for
the next round of sense is able to come
out so that they can manipulate them and
find all kinds of interesting things I
mean manipulate in the best possible
sense right so there are lots of
research there are lots of purposes on
the table it's not clear that they're
compatible with each other the next
question I think that that leads up to
is is is something that that each of you
i think is alluded to I'm going to take
Rudy's question first while you ponder
this and that is several of you talked
about this as a political non-starter
this sort of Ken's proposal to re really
radically I think reformulate the
question I think it should be a
beginning to come into view why this is
a political non-starter but I want to
talk about that in a minute but I want
to let professor to lagarza ask a
question
my sense of how I feel community has
taken over the native dimension is out
of real mg over the alleged benefits and
black shadow staff I've never understood
what I people thought in the better off
to be like why given the status apply
but so the whole hapless to create and I
get it in myself and a lot of workers
you know some of it where that was part
of that motivation which is a little
different with strongly connected to the
second point and this this I want to
defend part of the king's head and
Challenger litigated I've been an expert
witness on voting rights acts in texas
and florida in New England several
places per box and parking and one of
the things that I find increasingly
problematic is that first of all the
category of that he going praa 75 isn't
a racial category it's a language
academy now that really bizarre because
what you're not producing is a huge type
2 error you bring it everybody who has
allegedly Spanish language in your
backbone and call the bull or D because
of their
inability to speak English and you
participate fully in English now that
was very true when it came out of its
really very untrue for the native-born
Latino today that the major lawsuits
that are committed about Latino voting
discrimination and misrepresentations is
based on continued immigrant info
they're driving the demand for registry
now there's a logical problem e how is
it and again I am on the side of the
guys wanna criticize how is it that a
Mexican immigrant yesterday have the
right to sue for not being represented
today interesting logically that doesn't
make sense it could have been
discriminated here because they weren't
here but they get here so now they can
claim under the language provision
discrimination and they do it and this
is what I think what Kenneth propose is
essential to fix it somehow we need data
in their centers which we know men in
this other category of immigrant
generation so you can track moon other
bodies you know you put people like me
are you play great generation not of
Arizona with the guy from Mexico
and in the census essentially one of the
same that's nonsensical and only some
kind of change as you describe it can
get you out of that pot and knock the
hell out of all the litigators the
multiverse but maybe maybe a good I
don't want to take knock off point to
and I think he went before me but
they gone too far using the old remedy
for a problem that grief is not the same
as it once one cannot hear from the
litigator let me disagree with me but
you want to okay I mean there's a lot in
there so let's be clear so so I cover
this in about three weeks in my course
but here's the 30 second version in
order to establish in the redistricting
contest context a claim of
discriminatory impact you have to show
that the racial group is a politically
cohesive group that whites vote that
there's racially polarized voting that
there that the racial minority group
votes for certain candidates and though
and the majority let's say white vote
for a different candidate and that the
racial community is large enough so that
you could draw say a district in which
they would be able to elect their kin of
choice or have an equal opportunity to
do so ok so for purposes of the law
actually if a Latino community is not
politically cohesive so that that's a
old I grew up in Miami so I mean talk
about you know different types of Latino
community right so Cuban Americans are
going to be very different than then you
know Mexican Americans and more than
that older Cubans are going to be very
different than the newly more to younger
Cubans who've been here you know a third
generation but if they're not
politically cohesive okay don't worry
about it because I mean that if what
you're saying is true that there really
is no
identifying political cohesion to the
group no that's what I am I'm saying so
so but if it is true that they're going
to be different you know there may be
differences based on when people
immigrated etc and you are right that
the the fact that they are a language
minority status under the Voting Rights
Act which is actually I mean I wouldn't
put too much on the fact that it's
called a language minority as opposed to
a way to add to you know in the later
amendments the Voting Rights Act to add
other groups that are protected yes it's
true that they define it by language but
you know call an ethnic group or racial
group whatever you want it's just
another way to say alright these people
have a claim under the Voting Rights Act
and you know that that there are good
look there are plenty of people who
disagree with this type of litigation
for all kinds of reasons right in
Supreme Court look John Roberts things
this is unconstitutional I mean he said
so when he was a lawyer at the Justice
Department section 2 of the Voting
Rights Act this so you know you there
are plenty of people who take that view
but if you think that redistricting can
discriminate against the population and
we think that is a a problem that you
need to solve well then you know this
test that we have the standard is one
way of dealing with it now they're
plenty as I said plenty of reasons why
we don't we might say I shouldn't be
relevant the reducing process you
shouldn't pay attention to the creation
of majority minority districts they're
people who think that leads to the
balkanization of America order I mean if
you believe that then then the Voting
Rights Act is the problem it's not the
racial categories right but if we think
that it is a problem then you need some
kind of data to describe the community
and then make inferences about how they
should be represented you said say
quickly that as quickly as I can any way
that you you make an interesting
observation about the nature of the
Voting Rights Act that is to say that
when it comes
to Latinos it it sounds like what we're
talking about is a language minority
group but the litigation proceeds pretty
much on the assumption that what we're
talking about is a racial minority group
and the to get conflated although for
other purposes they're not conflated
depends on what the what's going on but
the the issue that you raised with
respect to immigrants of course n and
you must know this as an expert witness
in these cases but for purposes of
determining whether or not there is a
large large enough and coherent Latino
community for example you count the
voting age population but it's not just
voting age population not VAT just that
it's yvette the citizen voting age
population that's what gets counted now
that doesn't mean that immigration
doesn't have an impact on these cases I
remember years ago I lived in Los
Angeles for a few years and there was a
case that was litigated involving the LA
County Board of Supervisors a case
called Gaza in which I was lead counsel
for African Americans who intervened in
the case of protecting the interests of
the black community in the case grizzly
was bought by Latinos there's no
question that the case was filed when
the mexican-american community in LA
County because of immigration had
reached a certain stage and certain
point in time where the citizen voting
age population was large enough but
there's a lag between immigration and
that that point but it is it is impacted
by immigration no question about it but
it's only when you get to the point
where you have enough cbat that you can
actually use section 2 of the Voting
Rights Act in these cases the point you
make though the first point though is I
think a very interesting point I'm not
sure what to do with
so let me just ask Angelo a version of
Rudys question which is is I mean isn't
really right that you you benefit from
this classification policy that
conceptually illogically in some sense
from one point of view lumps together
recent immigrants with people who trace
their ancestry back eight generations
and find then find themselves in Mexico
yeah well I mean you know um on the
first question if you have in terms of
why Latinos might compare themselves to
blacks one of the things that's been
interesting is when you start to these
disaggregate that minority racial ethnic
minority category there's a hierarchy
there's a clearly hierarchy where you
have for example Latinos in fact seeing
in many places blacks as gatekeepers
it's all relative and then within the
Latino community here in New York for
example Dominican see Puerto Ricans as
gatekeepers and it goes on and on and on
so that yeah there is that kind of kind
of competition comparing the experiences
and it but it's already relative right
because we've all been taught thought
they say racial electric guitars are all
poor they're all of the same boat so it
gets kind of interesting when in a city
like New York two-thirds of the
population is now communities of color
we have to think about them in a
different way it's no longer white
versus non white or you know majority
versus minority and it gets complicated
so that there are various reasons why
there is that but I think the issue is
how you conceptualize kind of
discriminatory regimes and in the sense
of do you see it as a situation where
there are certain indicators based on a
pattern of discrimination that indicate
that they will likely be discrimination
against a person because of their
language because of this skin color
because of their foreignness or whatever
and do you have to wait to as a group
they develop a series of discriminatory
experiences before you're legit and you
can bring a case or can you in fact say
look it's likely that these people are
will be discriminated against can't be
discriminated against tomorrow so it's a
question of conceptually how you look at
this stuff because there's a case for
example in the some people in the black
community for example let's say
Latinos don't have any legitimate cases
in terms to bring in terms of
discrimination this is really we talk
about the civil rights movement and you
talk about trying to do this is
basically something that comes out of
the african-american experience in the
US the holiday adding the Latinos to
this thing and adding Asians and all
these groups so so it's really a
question of how you see this lead is
either kind of a narrow view of groups
that have experienced discrimination
because in the black community right you
have the same problem like with Haitians
and West Indians the hell are they doing
claiming affirmative action and getting
into all these programs whereas
african-americans experience you know
hundreds of years of discrimination and
getting you know so you wind up
with those kinds of discussions is is
that should you go that narrow is there
or do you take a broader kind of view of
trying to eliminate discrimination and
even anticipating situations where oops
because a certain characteristics will
probably more likely be discriminated
against so it's it's it's uh we've been
debating this for 30 years so i don't i
don't think i could result all right
well i don't think we're going to settle
a 30-year debate so but can't find that
purpose of the course two things just
remember what we said a couple of weeks
ago we said in the 19th century races
were biology we said in the 20th century
races were socially constructed and
we're saying in the 21st century they're
also affirmation and identity
constructed they're always statistically
constructed there is no conversation of
public there's no public policy
conversation that is not about the
statistical races because you got to go
count something and it's this
classification system that gives us
those counts I want to thank our guests
for a real
you